and in exchange for a sprat of warehouse persha,
add up, we exchanged one fan of Russia
for 200 warriors from the cob, we lost
50 of our people in exchange for
one verse
Today we have 215 good
new 215 definitely a win for our
state to study our success, the main thing
for 215 births will be able to get more of their
loved ones from the
Russian tract as a result of a complex
negotiation process on the exchange,
military personnel of the armed forces of the
Russian Federation of Donetsk and
Lugansk were returned to the Kiev regime of Ukraine tonight  republics that were in
mortal danger in captivity, at
present, all military personnel have been
delivered to the territory of the Russian
Federation by military transport aircraft and are in medical
institutions of the Russian Ministry of Defense; all
released military personnel are
given the opportunity to
contact their  relatives they
receive the necessary psychological
and medical assistance of
all won the cook at night to the house a
Saudi Arabian worm - this
will help Sim someone better than anyone Nast-Claude
niches the anthem fascinated George five
cities in exchange for them we saw 55 of those
who are not meritorious they are a pity but  I'm not in a hurry,
they took you Buddiki draining those who
fought against Ukraine and who are you who are the fools of
Ukraine, you who we definitely
won't demand